what is up
coders and people that watch my channel
my name is matt you're watching
go tech notorious and
today
we're gonna go over
the latest ancient archer updates what
is ancient archer you may ask
we'll start with the future
the next steps are to improve the
physics because there are physics
in the game now
it just uh aren't perfect and they
aren't fully integrated with
the whole model set up but they're
partially there
so you can do you can do some stuff and
also animations
so i've been working a lot on the
lighting and i've also done a lot of
work on the model loading to make sure
it brings in all the tangents all the
vectors you might need
but in reality the next big thing i need
to do here is i need to make it so the
physics
can
move around the objects because in all
previous versions i was just
i just hard coded all the movement
all the translations all the scaling
anything the models did where it was
hard coded
but now i can put a physics collider on
it and let that physics collider handle
where the model goes
and that is the future
however the current problem is well
i've i've ripped out
all the initial implementations of
all the move stuff so when you add a
collider it just puts everything in the
center of the world at zero zero so i've
got to do some work on that and that's
something that'll be done with this
version
[Music]
we are on version zero zero six yeah i
put out zero zero five i wanted to get
that one
just kind of capped off
and move on to this one
with physics and animations we should be
able to get a nice movable world
because currently
you can't really see it in the demo but
we could design a static world that
pretty much does what we want we could
have like you know a brick walls and
[Music]
ground and like you know we could
essentially design a level that you have
to walk through and go through and it
would not look like an open world and as
you can see i've implemented some walk
controls some movement the flashlight
you can turn on and off and also there
is
a uh aerial light which i can turn on
it's very bright and it's coming from
the angle of that sun thing the
interface stuff i'm gooey up here
um it's another thing that i want to
finish implementing because while it's
done it doesn't have a proper way to
actually hook up
variables and things that you want to
change
so we're going to add that along with
physics
before this version comes out and
hopefully the animations too those are
the big things
now there is pbr lighting hdr skies a
lot of stuff like that and i've covered
the basics of how this thing works in
the last couple vlogs basically just
build it link it and include
the ancient archer header
that is public here
and then you should be able to start
using all these public functions
so these are the ones you should use
if you're using it as a library just all
these public functions basically nothing
else
and this should be enough to encompass
generally
a game engine
but oh my
animations are are huge
so that'll be a really big step
and there's a lot to do we can sure we
can get them working but also we want to
be able to switch between them
and
have a system of which ones are loaded
up and make sure they're
they have proper tests to work with the
bones how they're supposed to work
and we are going to have to probably get
quaternions going because i did notice
in the physics
now i'm not mistaken this transform
basically has
a quaternion
and a location vector
yeah turning in and a vector
and we should be able to do all our
operations on that now another thing i
noticed that's kind of odd to reason
about is
models that have multiple objects within
them are multiple meshes so my loader
will load them all up and display them
but i also
need to
consider whether i want to have them
attached to each other via child parent
relationships and i guess that's up to
the scene but i always thought that they
should be generally attached
i'll show you some examples okay so one
of the things i've done
is uh changed my node info a lot now
what is node info
sort of a core little element that
basically each of these is a node in the
world and they can have a vao texture
girl ids so these can be drawn they can
be
moved around this is sort of like the
core game elements but they're notes so
you can have
a parent-child relationship of them all
and some models are built like that and
i'm trying to figure out how modular or
large i should make this should i put
more
stuff should i put some add-on
capability kind of working on a little
method like that
to to go here but for now it is what it
is we've got the physics we've got the
draw info
and
that's typically what we're going to be
working with before we draw because we
we check where it's at based on its
physics body and we put it in that
position and then we draw it
so that's essentially all this
little node thing is right now you know
i've gone back and forth here do i
really want to have
all this info
here
so our props all have a bunch of note
info they have a vector of node info
called the meshes
and we typically only work with the
front one when we're moving stuff around
the first node
and that we saved if
if we try to you know when you load a
model usually they have an empty node
and then they have the real stuff
so if the node was empty we don't save
that one we only save the real stuff but
we might want to save that real one
or save the initial transform
also i added
a library
a manifest thing so now in properties if
you go to use
vc
peace
manifest switch this to yes it should
automatically grab all the libraries and
i'm not sure if this works uh correctly
yet
so someone if anyone tests it let me
know or if anyone knows how to make it
actually right uh feel feel free to uh
edit it on this branch this v006 branch
because i don't think it's right let me
show you but i have something to learn
here files
and here we go go to the top and this
here this json file let's take a look at
it so it's just this little manifest
thing and it's supposed to have all the
dependencies i don't know
what all this stuff does to be honest
you know how to fix up this file uh let
me know i dug into it a little bit but
it wasn't very clear how to do these so
it's pretty easy to manually install
them so it's not that big of a deal
but it would just be nice if it auto
work as i've turned on the manifest it
seems to have broken some things so i'm
going to turn that back off for now
and let's go back to properties
v c pkg use manifest to know until we
get that fixed
so there's that all right let me show
you example of
a little bit of a world and some stuff
loading up
[Music]
all right i had to dig in and fix just a
few things but this should do yeah it's
hard to see let's turn on the lights
so uh okay those are broken
the cubes are huge but
the
physics box inside them it's got a
really tiny physics box so that's why
this looks so hot
but i was just testing something i want
to be able to get the physics box to
automatically increase depending on the
starting mesh so that's something in
progress and it should be done for this
version but it's actually not done right
now
so we're gonna we're gonna change that
back before we show the example so in my
example project i have a set models that
is called
uh every run and that's where i
basically do all my little sample stuff
and you can see
that i'm loading a bunch of test ground
okay so i made these 10x green cubes
that's what it's loading up that doesn't
look right but we're going to change
this to
a different cube a normal cube so you
can see here that we're adding physics
it defaults to box defaults to sphere
it's just a one by one
as you can see now we're in the world
and those do have proper physics and
they also have emission textures so i
did get the base
for emission working
and that way we can do neon signs or
whatever still use some glow effect to
look better and as you can see the world
is much expanded i guess you can
actually walk to the edge got a little
sprint button
but there's no falling off the the
bottom plane just goes in this endlessly
which is potential now what i thought
about doing for a basic starter sample
is actually take these uh these ground
plates or whatever the ground planes
and i could essentially shift and reuse
them so that they stay centered on the
character
but not a true centered so they don't
move
so the ones that are furthest away back
there will snap to the front and the
draw over here or something like that
so uh you could make an endless runner
system or an endless world by just using
the same nine planes with the repeating
texture
let me get some of some models loading
up because
if you're in debug mode it's going to
show you
all the stuff that's going on in general
i got a lot of debug stuff
this doesn't show and release
so optimizes all that away i optimize
the texture and model loading so that if
you keep loading the same
model over and over
it only loads it once and reuses the
node info for basically otherwise so
there's a lot of uh there have been a
lot of improvements already and same for
textures if it's already got one loaded
even if it's an internal texture it will
properly reuse
most internal textures as long as
they're from the same model
so that's cool because at one point this
was super spammy spawning a bunch of
these little cubes
uh spammed it uh that many times but
once i optimized the way it only spams
once and then it just reuses that one
anytime you say load this one again
a nice little optimization and as you
load up models it tells you
uh what it's finding all right let's
make a few changes
in our trusty model loader file this is
where
most the magic happens and we keep track
of all the loaded models this also helps
with unloading them too
because these have reference counts
so you will see a reference count now in
theory i should probably use
something else instead of this reference
count variable
like a shared pointer or something might
actually be better in this sort of case
so potential redesigns to be more modern
but i'm not sure if it's actually worth
my time to do all that because it might
be
the exact same efficient and that's one
of the things you learn about coding
after a while yeah there's all these
little tricks you can do all over the
place and the more you learn the more
little tricks you can do
but at some point you just want things
to work and if it's working you leave it
alone maybe you could refactor it and
it'd be fun or cooler but
if it already works and does what it's
supposed to do it's kind of
a waste of time to refactor it has to
have some sort of
performance improvement or
much more readable and easier to
understand
but if none of those are the case you
might as well just leave it on the
process mesh somewhere in here we should
have a little load of materials right it
tells you what kind of shady model
picked up this is all using them the
asymptotic asset importer library all
right so if we get a base diffuse
texture we should say something
yeah so it should be saying something
there
[Music]
okay here it is
it just okay it hasn't split between
this loaded so the first time it loads
the texture a new texture it will say
but if it reuses one it doesn't really
say so i could put some spam in here to
say like it reused
but that's all done in the material
textures because all this does is return
or fill out this textures uh unordered
map
and it might fill it out with stuff re
that already exists in this load
material textures we have quite a big
checker that does a lot of different
things but it really just ensures that
it loads the texture if it has it so it
tries from embedded it tries to reuse if
it's already loaded it manages
the list of all loaded textures if we
load up a new one so this load material
textures is quite a function
and i spent a lot of time
making sure it works properly and does
the proper thing and same with the model
loader so those are always being
improved
all i really need to do to make the rest
of my stuff show is take these capsule
colliders off of them these capsules are
really tiny and these models are really
huge
so if i load up a bunch of these
uh let's load up a few more this guy
and here we are as you can see there are
three models
and all that stuff so we can walk over
here and and take a look at these guys
and we have
a flashlight that we're pointing so as
we get closer we show more light but the
the light is coming from approximately
the angle of this skybox so it's
actually lighting up their back which
looks a little you know we start over
here in this in the center we're looking
at their unlit side so they are this
these are basically backlit models
there's not a whole lot of front
lighting just whatever the directional
lights ambient is showing everywhere of
course and
if i turn on my flashlight here
we can get a look at how that looks
okay so here's my little radius light
and here it is and i have a function
down below that says if the radius light
exists or has been
it's not negative one it should move and
stay on the player so i'll hit play
again i'll show you just show you that
and i got i should probably turn down
the sound on this it's really loud isn't
it and you'll see there's a a light that
seems to be following us around
you are seeing here normal and specular
loaded on these models so they are
looking pretty good
i've got
some work to do on
[Music]
normal stuff because either i'm doing it
wrong or i'm understanding
it wrong and implementing it wrong and
this is just fong lighting essentially
we also don't have shadows as you may
have noticed so we are going to work on
that too the shadows
should be coming and as we add shadows
it's gonna a lot of other things are
kind of gonna come with it
like the hdr skies come along with
shadows
why is that because they both
essentially work the same way they both
basically take a cube map
screenshot
of the world around you
and then they use that as a reflection
map and essentially kind of save those
as textures so once we figure that out
we'll be able to do all sorts of post
processing there is no post processing
currently
there we could put up walls and blockers
and design game logic and go through
dungeons or whatever we could do all
that stuff
look forward to seeing some big stuff
happen in these next versions we're kind
of out of the initial total noob phase
which is nice and i'm looking forward to
doing more programming's hard guys if
you're working on stuff that
uh you know is a lot of progress for you
be really proud of yourselves that's my
big tip because it's really easy to go
find people that are further ahead of
you especially with how easy it is to
just go look up stuff like everyone you
look at on
social media and stuff they always seem
like they're way farther than you and
that's fine
congratulate them but also
you know you can learn from them but i
guess the point i'm trying to make here
is
try not to compare yourself to others
it's real easy to get uh demoralized
if you do that and that's something i've
been working on i've actually taken a
little bit of time off you might notice
just to like
focus on myself and my mentality and
make sure
that uh i'm not
doing stuff like that because it really
messes me up and it's not really fair to
me or you guys or anyone that looks up
to me so stick with it i appreciate you
guys and a special shout out to the
patrons of this channel you are making
these videos possible it does mean a lot
if you want to support me further you
can go sign up over there
and you also get access to all the stuff
i post over there and i've been posting
a lot more
kind of more uh
my thought process and uh explaining
some things and stuff like that we also
have a discord you're welcome to join
there
everyone's been super cool over there
just you know it's more places to talk
about things or get opinions on stuff
but i've got some other productions
coming up this month so look forward to
those
all right keep coding you guys i will
see you guys in the next video peace out
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you